Hola Muy Bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de la entrevista de frontini 4 en
español nos acompaña en esta oportunidad
valia guilliams ella fue mormona O sea
que integró la iglesia de Jesucristo de
los Santos de los Últimos Días desde
1984 hasta el año 2014 y la abandonó con
muchos cuestionamientos y sobre todo con
un profundo conocimiento de lo que
ocurre al interior del mormonismo valía
Guillén Muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en la entrevista de Franz 24
en español
gracias a vosotros encantada de
participar vale en primer lugar por
supuesto preguntarte y para que toda
nuestra audiencia lo conozca No qué
caracteriza a la iglesia mormona cuáles
son sus bases y sus principios
bueno la iglesia mormona se caracteriza
por tener unas escrituras
podíamos decir complementarias a la
Biblia
está basada en el libro de mormón no que
supuestamente narra acontecimientos
ocurridos en la América precolombina y
una supuesta visita de Jesucristo a esas
tierras no
y sostiene que
los nativos americanos descenderían de
una tribu de Israel que habría viajado
desde
tierras hebreas hasta hasta América y
habría fundado allí dos grandes
civilizaciones bueno con millones de
personas se habían se habrían
desenvuelto guerras y muchos
acontecimientos pero de los cuales no
habría ninguna evidencia ni histórica
cultural arqueológica
sin ningún tipo
vaya a usted estuvo en esta religión
entre 1984 y 2014 estamos hablando de 30
años no bastante tiempo que le acercó
por un lado y que la terminó de alejar
bueno
es el argumento con el que se acercan no
los que realizan el proselitismo Mormón
el proselitismo de la iglesia que está a
cargo de Misioneros que
ocupan dos años de su vida para difundir
la palabra de Dios la las visiones de
José Smith y
el libro de mormón y bueno en una de
esas Pues a la salida del colegio me
encontraron
uno acepta recibir las charlas que
constan de seis lecciones en las que
explican cómo va todo en qué consiste la
este sistema de creencias o esta
religión y bueno con una serie de
promesas que bueno a las personas que
tendríamos alguna vulnerabilidad no
emocional alguna carencia o estuviéramos
pasando algunos momentos difíciles en
nuestra vida Pues nos convencen y nos
atrae para
asomarnos a esa religión y ese era mi
caso y
ingresé así con con la ilusión de
pertenecer a
esa organización y de salvarme no y
Bueno claro no apuntaban a cualquier
persona definitivamente iban hacia
quienes presentaban determinadas
características por lo que usted no se
está contando ahora cuéntenos la iglesia
de jesucristos de los Santos de los
Últimos Días recibió múltiples denuncias
muchísimas vinculadas a abusos sexuales
no incluidos menores de edad usted
sufrió algún tipo de abuso o fue testigo
no no no Allí se da todo de manera
encubierta
no me enteré por lo menos yo en mi radio
cercano No vi ningún caso pero ya uno se
entera de eso pues una vez sale a la luz
y ya se han
desenvuelto las condenas no de estos
casos y se suelen dar en Estados Unidos
muchísimo y lo que se tiende a hacer es
culpar a la víctima Y tratar de esconder
estos hechos no
básicamente Esa esa ha sido la dinámica
Pero
últimamente ha salido a la luz
precisamente por la
por las noticias que
que han sacado a la luz estos estos
sucesos no no y sin lugar a dudas no es
ni la única iglesia ni la única religión
cuyos líderes o representantes son
acusados de abusos sexuales pero sí
estamos ante una religión y una iglesia
con muchas particularidades verdad y
algo vinculado esto tiene que ver con
requisitos que marcan muchísimo el
estilo de vida de quienes integran el
mormonismo no y un elemento clave es el
control verdad hasta dónde llega este
control
Exacto el control es absoluto es
absoluto Pero se da de una manera
bastante encubierta porque ellos se
muestran abiertos Y tolerantes no y todo
lo que hacen es recomendar a las
personas pero en realidad no es más que
chantaje emocional no pero
abarca a todos los aspectos de nuestra
vida financieramente
obviamente moralmente y bueno está todo
involucrado uno como viste lo que
ingiere y el bolsillo principalmente es
una
utilización de recursos de la persona en
todos los aspectos
hablaba bueno precisamente no del
bolsillo del aspecto financiero no de la
vida de las personas a esto apunta mi
próxima pregunta no porque veníamos
hablando de polémicas no denuncias de
abusos etcétera y otra polémica tiene
que ver con la acumulación de dinero no
y el diezmo que tiene que dar sus
integrantes cuéntenos Cómo funciona esto
y Cómo afecta a la vida de quienes
pertenecen a la religión mormona
sí nuevamente esta extracción de
recursos se da por chantaje emocional no
prometiéndole a la adepto que va a
recibir bendiciones si es que cumple
dando un diezmo íntegro que significa
dar 10 el 10% de los ingresos de la
persona y claro
se podía decir que es una agrupación
bastante elitista Porque
al menos en Estados Unidos los diezmos
son muy generosos Estados Unidos
Australia Europa podíamos decir no y
bueno en el caso de los países en vías
de desarrollo pues uno da lo que puede
pero
se trata de mucho dinero el cual
hábilmente ellos invierten en otras
multinacionales
farmacéuticas Google
Eh bueno
en redes sociales y hacen
estratégicamente
inversiones cosa de que hoy en día han
logrado acumular 100 mil millones de
dólares para vamos
en dinero se podía decir que en metálico
Claro que estamos hablando de un diezmo
que otorgan millones de personas a lo
largo de todo el mundo pasemos ahora a
otro tema del cual se ha hablado
muchísimo no de esta religión que tiene
que ver con la poligamia
tradicionalmente sea asociado este
estilo de vida amormones al menos en los
inicios de la iglesia pero le quiero
preguntar a usted no que ha estado muy
vinculada a esta religión sí ocurriendo
Y qué ideas sustentan y justifican sobre
todo este estilo de vida y perdón suma
otra pregunta más qué idea de mujer está
de fondo de esta práctica
claro bueno esta práctica lo que ellos
promueven es que se ha dado por
revelación no se ha dado para momentos
concretos en la historia de la iglesia
donde bueno
habían pocos miembros los hombres morían
en Las Guerras y había que proteger a
las viudas entonces bueno se le había
dado a esta revelación a José Smith al
fundador de que practicase la poligamia
para bueno dar un equilibrio
demográfico proteger a las viudas y una
serie de pretextos Pero él bueno
se llegó a casar con mujeres desde niñas
de 14 años hasta mujeres ya casadas con
otros hombres
práctica que se llama la poliandria no y
Pero bueno llegó en family Search que es
una página de la iglesia se llega a
contabilizar a más de 50 esposas
entonces bueno como eso era ilegal en
Estados Unidos
en esos tiempos
se llega el gobierno llega a perseguir
la poligamia y ellos se ven obligados a
suspender la práctica pero
habían
grupos Rebeldes podíamos decir que
consideraban eso un mandamiento sagrado
y optaron por irse por su parte a seguir
practicando la poligamia ya y ahora
podíamos decir que hay su agrupaciones
que las siguen practicando especialmente
en los estados de Estados Unidos
de Yuta
Idaho y algunas partes de México también
que se han establecido pequeños planes
que siguen fieles a la palabra original
o a la revelación original que se le
habría dado a José Smith por parte
divina
varias nos queda poco tiempo no quiero
dejar de preguntarle lo siguiente no en
este contexto y teniendo este
conocimiento el Segundo habitante de
Primera mano no de lo que es el
mormonismo cree que qué locura a esta
iglesia cree que tendrá más vida o cree
que estamos llegando quizás a su final
Sí yo creo que lo segundo estamos
llegando ya estamos viendo un ocaso
porque
a partir del 2012 podíamos decir que se
ha producido un Boom no de internet y la
difusión de información de papeles o y
documentos originales no que
enseñan los orígenes de la iglesia y
bueno
masivamente la gente ha visto que todo
lo que le habían contado entre ellos me
incluyo pues no era lo que decía ser No
aparte de tener políticas bastante
arbitrarias no como con la gente lgbt
racismo homofobia bueno y casos que
que bueno se está quedando realmente
obsoleta y muchos temas varias Perdón
que nos tocado dejar por fuera porque
Hemos llegado Se nos acabó el tiempo
llegamos al final de esta entrevista Le
Quiero agradecer muchísimo su testimonio
Muchas gracias realmente a vosotros A
vosotros Muchísimas gracias No gracias a
usted una vez más y a nuestra audiencia
por supuesto como siempre la invitamos a
que sigan informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación y en francés 24.com
sigan junto a nosotros
[Música]